.
Ein Luzerner Unternehmer
kämpft um seine Firma.
Wir möchten sie nicht entlassen.
Wir möchten ja nur arbeiten.
Corona bringt das Unternehmen
zum Stillstand.
Es tut weh, es tut mir selber weh.
Eine Künstlerin muss alles absagen.
Es ist so,
dass ich momentan keinen Lohn habe.
Corona gefährdet ihre Existenz.
Ich bin froh um den Sozialstaat
und möchte ihn nicht aushöhlen.
Luzerns grösster Souvenirhändler
ist fassungslos:
Man konnte sich nicht vorstellen,
dass eine Pandemie
solche Auswirkungen haben kann.
Der Touristen-Hotspot ist leer.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen,
dass wieder Touristen kommen.
Und: Zwei Luzerner Freunde
betreiben ein Hotel.
Sie geben alles,
um das Haus zu retten.
Es macht auch traurig,
wenn so wenig Leute kommen.
Jetzt gilt wirklich nur noch:
Vollgas vorwärts.
Ihre Geschichten in:
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Kirchenglocken *
Es ist Sommer.
Drei Monate nach dem Shutdown
im Frühjahr 2020
bemühen sich die Menschen in Luzern
um Normalität.
Die Massnahmen wurden gelockert,
und man sehnt sich nach dem Leben,
wie es vor Corona war.
In Willisau
bereiten die Mitarbeitenden
des grössten Zeltbauers der Schweiz,
der Firma Hunziker,
ein Grillfest vor.
Mitten in der schlimmsten Krise
des 85-jährigen Unternehmens.
Wegen Corona
sind alle grosse Events abgesagt.
Jetzt will CEO Roland Küng
die Belegschaft nicht allein lassen.
Hoi, geht's gut?
- Hoi, Paul.
Warst du nach Feierabend vorne?
Nein, ich sagte doch,
heute sei nichts - Kirchenpatron.
Ahm ja, die haben ja Kirchenpatron.
Die 70 Mitarbeitenden des KMU sind
in Kurzarbeit - die meisten zu Hause.
Umso mehr geniessen sie
das Wiedersehen -
Schulter an Schulter und maskenfrei,
wie im Juni 2020 üblich.
Liebe
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter.
Herzlichen Dank, dass ihr
so zahlreich erschienen sind.
Es hat mich sehr gefreut, dass ihr
euch so zahlreich angemeldet habt.
Ich garantiere euch,
dass sich die Geschäftsleitung
mit Haut und Haaren
für euch einsetzt,
damit wir die Firma
am Leben erhalten,
damit ihr
einen gesicherten Arbeitsplatz habt.
Irgendwann geht es weiter.
Eine grosse Sorge von mir ist,
dass der eine oder andere
vielleicht irgendwann sagt:
"Jetzt habe ich
genug vom Zu-Hause-Sitzen."
"Dort könnte ich
wenigstens arbeiten."
Ich hoffe,
dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Nächstes Jahr geht es weiter.
Dann brauchen wir jeden von euch.
Wir gehen jetzt an den Grill,
aber der ganze Rest ist dann
individuell und selbstständig.
Vielen Dank.
Der Chef persönlich steht am Grill -
nur die Schürze fehlt.
Ich wollte sagen ...
Hast du die mitgenommen?
Es kam mir eben erst in den Sinn.
Sonst binde ich mir einen Abfallsack
um. Ich nehme Poulet und Würste.
Ich möchte für meine Mitarbeitenden
ein Zeichen setzen.
Heute
grilliert die Geschäftsleitung.
Die Leute dürfen sich hinsetzen
und bedienen lasse.
Der 50-Jährige übernahm die Leitung
der Firma vor zweieinhalb Jahren.
Der gelernte Käser und Maurer
scheint bei der Belegschaft
den richtigen Ton zu treffen.
Ich bin einfach mit Herzblut dabei.
Das ist für mich kein Thema.
Meine Aufgabe ist klar:
Ich sage immer:
Alle Mitarbeiter sind an Weihnachten
daheim mit ihrem Familien
unter dem Weihnachtsbaum.
Und sie haben einen festen Job.
Das ist meine Aufgabe.
Ein grosses Versprechen
in so unsicheren Zeiten.
Beim Team kommt das an.
Entschuldigung.
Die Freude ist wieder da.
Es stimmt einen optimistisch.
Poulet oder Rind?- Ein wenig Rind
und ein wenig Poulet.
Fredi, willst du noch
eine halbe Wurst?- Im Moment nicht.
Aber beim zweiten Gang?
- Ja, ja.
Fredi Lipp
steuert die grossen Trucks.
Jetzt nutzt er
die freie Zeit für Radtouren.
Fährst du viel Velo?
Ich habe die 1'000-km-Marke
überschritten.
Es fragt sich: runter, rauf
oder geradeaus? Das sind ja Welten.
Etwas muss man machen.
Man braucht einen Tagesablauf
und etwas Struktur.
Gerade in der Krise
sollen die Angestellten spüren,
dass der Chef hinter ihnen steht.
Mit diesen Damen und Herren
verdienen wir unser Geld.
Diese Damen und Herren halten unsere
Firma am Leben - jahrein, jahraus.
Ich fühle mich verantwortlich,
für sie da zu sein,
für sie zu sorgen.
Das ist mein Job
als Geschäftsführer dieser Firma.
Doch das Ausmass der Krise wird CEO
Küng mehr und mehr Sorge bereiten.
In der Touristenstadt Luzern
bleiben im Sommer 2020
die Gäste aus dem Ausland weg.
Die Logiernächte sind eingebrochen.
Eine Luzerner Hotelgruppe
streicht über 100 Stellen -
eine Massenentlassung.
Auch dem Boutiquehotel Beau Séjour
steht das Wasser bis zum Hals.
Es kommen zwar vermehrt
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
aber nur bei schönem Wetter.
Manuel Berger ist froh um jeden Gast.
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Und dir?
- Auch, danke.
Ich möchte einen Apéro trinken.
- Bist du verabredet?
Ja, mit zwei Leuten.
- Jemand sitzt schon dort hinten.
Sicher?- Ja.
- Dann schaue ich nach.
Anders als im letzten Sommer
werden Zimmer storniert
oder gar nicht erst gebucht.
Das sieht momentan so aus.
Ich zeige den Vergleich
zu anderen Jahren.
Das ist z.B. die gleiche Periode
im Jahr 2019.
Man sieht also,
dass es vereinzelt freie Zimmer gab.
Das ist eine Auslastung von
ca. 98-99 % in der gleichen Periode.
Wenn man dann wieder zurückgeht,
sieht das aktuell so aus.
Das ist ca. drei Viertel weniger.
Ich habe mich die letzten
zwei Monate immer davor geschützt,
zu viel in das System zu schauen.
Das bricht einem schon das Herz,
wenn man sieht,
dass so wenig Leute kommen.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
Manuel Berger führt das Beau Séjour
gemeinsam mit seinem Geschäftspartner
Walter Willy Willimann.
Ohne Ausländer überleben wir nicht,
das ist einfach so.
Es geht allen so.
Und das geht sehr schnell.
Man muss offen sein,
sonst geht es bergab.
Das kann man sich noch drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben Wochen erlauben,
und dann ist auch
der Kredit des Bundes weg.
Also, mit Freunden und Familie,
die am Wochenende übernachten,
überlebt niemand.
Das ist so.
Aber hey ...
Von den Schweizern alleine
kann die Hotellerie nicht leben,
denn nur der Schweizer
hat die Möglichkeit zu sagen:
"Oh, schlechtes Wetter.
Wir gehen nicht weg."
Dann stehen wieder
ein paar 100 Hotels leer.
Denn die Schweizer sagen:
"Ich muss ja nicht gehen."
Luzern hat etwas geschlafen, hat
sich auf den Lorbeeren ausgeruht
und sehr auf ausländischen Tourismus
gesetzt hat.
Nicht wie die Bergregionen,
z.B. das Engadin,
das einen sehr hohen Anteil
an Schweizern hat.
Das hilft uns jetzt nicht viel.
Der Bund unterstützt die Branche
mit 40 Mio. Fr. Hilfsgeldern -
die Hälfte für Marketing-Massnahmen.
Aber dieses Video löst bei
den Hoteliers keine Begeisterung aus.
Wenn du Zeit brauchst
für dich und deine Lieben,
dann brauchst du Schweiz.
Es zeigt keine Stadt.
Es zeigt nur Natur.
Nur Natur, Natur, Natur.
D.h. also, das ist das Ende
der Stadthotellerie.
Man kann nicht genau sagen,
ob uns das etwas bringt.
Vermutlich nicht unbedingt.
Wie das Haus
vor der Schliessung bewahren?
Ratlosigkeit macht sich breit.
Eine Touristenstadt
ohne ausländische Gäste.
Das trifft Luzerns grössten
Souvenirhändler mitten ins Herz.
Und doch gibt sich Robert Casagrande
umtriebig wie eh und je.
Hallo, zusammen. Alles gut?
- Danke, tipptopp.
Deine Uhr läuft?- Ja. Ich habe
noch eine Uhr für den Service.
Ah, super. Danke.
Nimmst du sie am Dienstag mit?
- Ja, Dienstag ist gut.
Tschüss, Roberto.
- Tschüss.
Im Casagrande-Stammhaus
herrscht Flaute.
Hello Ladies.
- Good morning.
Good morning, how are you?
Hattet ihr schon viel zu tun?
Eine Reparatur vielleicht
von meinem Freund?
Ja, die ist da.- Ich muss sie
am Dienstag mitnehmen.
Wenn das geht.
Ich weiss nicht, was ...
Ja, ich werde das schreiben.
- Gut.
Und sonst war's noch ruhig
heute Morgen?
Sehr ruhig.
Wir hatten zwei oder drei Kunden.
Okay, gut. Aber das ist natürlich
nicht wie früher.- Nein.
Vor Corona war das Geschäft
dank chinesischen und indischen
Reisegruppen eine Goldgrube.
Ein Rucksacktourist.
Er muss
wieder zurück zu seiner Gruppe.
Hier hat es Schokolade,
die wir mit 50 % Rabatt verkaufen.
Das hat damit zu tun,
dass sie entweder Ende Juni
oder im Juli abläuft.
Normalerweise sind die Inder
unsere besten Kunden für Schokolade.
Sie nehmen die tütenweise mit.
Jetzt ist Hauptsaison für die Inder:
April, Mai, Juni, Juli.
Wir werden zu viel an Lager haben.
Wir haben im Moment
ca. 20 Paletten im Lager.
Die müssen wir
bis nächsten Januar abbauen.
Beim Treppenaufgang
haben wir unseren Casiboy.
Das ist
die Geschichte meiner Eltern,
die das Geschäft
1948 eröffnet haben.
Meine Eltern
haben mit 80 Fr. angefangen.
Ich habe immer gewusst:
Das ist das, was ich machen will.
Ich bin eigentlich
der geborene Verkäufer.
Mit 16 war ich hier im Laden
schon der beste Verkäufer.
Ich half in jeder Pause,
manchmal auch über Mittag, hier aus.
Ich wusste: Das ist meine Zukunft.
Ich wollte das Geschäft zusammen
mit meinem Bruder übernehmen.
Mit Erfolg.
Die beiden Brüder
besitzen heute in der ganzen Stadt
fünf Filialen
und mehrere Liegenschaften.
Im zweiten Stock sind die Toiletten.
Es hat natürlich einen Grund,
warum sie im zweiten Stock sind.
So müssen die Leute durch den ganzen
Laden gehen und uns beglücken.
Auf der Toilette gibt es die Mög-
lichkeit, heisses Wasser zu tanken.
Die Chinesen haben
teils ihre eigenen Suppen dabei.
Dafür haben sie so kleine Gefässe,
die wir im Notfall
natürlich auch verkaufen.
Dazu brauchen sie
heisses oder kaltes Wasser.
Das können sie bei uns tanken.
Doch die Chinesen
bleiben schon seit Januar 2020 aus.
106 Angestellte sind in Kurzarbeit.
Ja, es tut weh,
aber ich kann es nicht ändern.
Was nützt es mir, wenn ich
nach Hause gehe und traurig bin?
Ich muss doch
meine Leute weiter motivieren.
Ausserdem bin ich
ein optimistischer Mensch.
* Spieluhrenmelodie:
"Nach em Räge schint d'Sonne" *
"Nach em Räge schint d'Sonne."
# Nach em Räge schint Sunne,
nach em Briegge wird glacht.
# Du li duli duli ho,
ho duli duli ho.
# Ho duli, duli ho.
Bei der Firma Hunziker in Willisau
steht fast alles still.
Nur der Werkhofchef
bewegt ab und zu die Lastwagen,
um Standschäden zu vermeiden.
Normalerweise wäre jetzt Hochbetrieb
und wir wären alle im Stress.
Man würde sich auf den Feierabend
oder auf die Ferien freuen.
Und jetzt ist es sehr speziell.
Jetzt hatten die Kinder
ein wenig Ferien.
Mit ihnen haben ich
ab und zu etwas unternommen.
Daheim habe ich das Haus renoviert.
Geschäftsführer Roland Küng
setzt die Situation zu.
In diesen Zeiten
plant niemand einen Event.
Die Festzelte bleiben im Lager.
Da hilft auch der Bundeskredit
von bisher 500'000 Fr. wenig.
Es ist jetzt absolute Hochsaison.
Das würde hier
ganz anders zu- und hergehen.
Der Disponent, der täglich Fahrten
und Personal einteilt.
"Wo müssen wir noch nachschieben?
Ich brauche noch fünf Temporäre."
Er wäre sehr beschäftigt,
aber die Leute sind alle daheim.
Sie sind alle seit April daheim.
Brigitte, geht's?
Bringen wir es hoch?
- Ja, es klappt.
Die Geschäftsleitung hofft,
dass der Bundesrat
Grossanlässe über 1'000 Personen
bald wieder zulässt.
Mir geht es heute nicht so gut.
Ich bin nervös.
Die Bundesrat-PK,
die heute wieder ansteht.
Man hört Verschiedenes
aus den Medien,
in welche Richtung es gehen soll.
Ein gutes Gefühl habe ich nicht.
Eben las ich die neusten Zahlen.
Heute hat das BAG 274 gemeldet.
Das sind wieder mehr.
Ja, es ...
Nein, ich habe kein gutes Gefühl.
Der Leiter für Logistik,
Philipp Waser,
wurde
kurz vor dem Shutdown angestellt.
Auch er hofft auf eine Lockerung,
um endlich arbeiten zu können.
(Bundespräsidentin Sommaruga im TV)
Der Bundesrat hat darum entschieden,
das Verbot um einen Monat
zu verlängern, bis Ende September.
Danach können die Kantone
Grossanlässe unter
strengen Auflagen wieder bewilligen.
Was denkt ihr, was das heisst?
Es ist etwas und es ist doch nichts.
Es wurde einfach etwas verzögert.
Wir haben nicht erwartet,
dass es einen Freipass gibt.
Ich mache mir Sorgen um den Winter.
"Unter strengen Auflagen",
das ist in vielen Situationen
bei Events nicht umsetzbar.
CEO Küng weiss:
Für die Firma und die Belegschaft
könnte das grosse Konsequenzen haben.
Die finanzielle Situation
ist momentan so,
dass wir je nach Monat ...
... äh ... irgendwo ...
... zwischen 250'000 und 350'000
Minus machen.
Ein sehr grosser Teil davon
sind Personalkosten.
Das heisst natürlich konkret ...
Ich spreche es an: Personalkosten.
Die müssen weiter runter.
Das bedeutet: Entlassungen.
Was mich persönlich berührt hat,
ist:
Roland ist einer, der das Ganze
sehr optimistisch sieht.
Wir haben im Dreierteam davon
gesprochen, dass es weitergeht.
Roland sagte:
"Im Herbst geht es sicher weiter."
Jetzt ist er selber
sehr verunsichert.
Das habe ich aufgenommen und bin
selbst noch mehr verunsichert.
Wir müssen ...
Wir müssen da irgendwie durchkommen.
Der Logistikchef startete
bei Hunziker im November 2019.
Kaum angekommen, traf ihn
der Shutdown mit voller Wucht.
Die Stelle als COO
wurde ja frisch ausgeschrieben.
Die gab es in dieser Form noch nie
in dieser 85-jährigen
Hunziker-Geschichte.
Ich kam mit Stolz hierher und
durfte diese Funktion übernehmen.
Roland Küng sagte,
ich hätte drei Monate Zeit,
um mich einzuarbeiten.
Dann würde es so richtig losgehen.
Und dann kam der Lockdown.
Ich muss realistisch sein und sagen:
Allenfalls
trifft es sogar meine Stelle.
Das ist gut möglich.
Das bekommen wir
nächste Woche schon hin.
Schauen wir am Freitag, wie
das geht. Das wird schon gutgehen.
Danke für den kurzfristigen Einsatz.
Schönen Abend.
- Schönen Abend. Tschüss.
Küng hofft noch immer,
dass einige der geplanten Events
durchgeführt werden.
Aber die Unsicherheit ist gross.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass der Spengler Cup -
das eigentliche Turnier in der Arena.
Wie es
mit unseren Aufträgen aussieht ...
Ich zweifle.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Wenn ich den Januar anschaue,
in dem wir sehr, sehr viel Arbeit
haben ... Das WEF.
Das WEF in Davos, international.
Das WEF soll kleiner werden,
habe ich gehört.
Braucht es noch Side Events daneben?
Schutzkonzepte ...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich bin aber
wirklich nicht optimistisch.
Küngs Versprechen
an seine Mitarbeitenden,
dass sie Weihnachten
mit einem sicheren Job feiern können,
scheint in immer weitere Ferne
zu rücken.
Den Sommer hindurch
läuft der Hotelbetrieb im Beau Séjour
recht ordentlich.
Dank der Schweizer Gäste, die fast
alle im eigenen Land Ferien machen.
An diesem Wochenende sind
alle 28 Zimmer des Hotels ausgebucht.
Vier Luzerner lassen zu ihrem
30. Geburtstag eine Party steigen
und haben das ganze Hotel
für zwei Tage gemietet.
Das ist in einem solchen
schwierigen Sommer sehr wichtig.
Unsere Auslastung ist nicht mehr
das, was sie im letzten Jahr war.
Da sind Grossanlässe
einerseits toll,
weil so viele Leute
auf's Mal im Beau Séjour sind,
andererseits natürlich auch,
dass es ein wenig Umsatz gibt.
Es ist schön, dass das Haus
einmal ausgelastet ist.
Wenn auch nur für eine Nacht,
aber das ist super.
Das ist auch eine emotionale Sache,
weil es toll ist, wieder zu starten
und einen Grossanlass machen können.
Es stand ja lange genug
in den Sternen,
wann und in welcher Form
das wieder möglich sein wird.
* Dynamische Musik *
Um das Fest ausrichten zu können,
hat Manuel Berger
Servicefachleute dazugemietet.
Kein Aufwand ist ihm zu gross.
85 Gäste sollen hier
speisen und feiern können.
Die aktuellen Corona-Regeln
lassen das zu,
allerdings
muss um Mitternacht Schluss sein.
Für die Geburtstagskinder
war es eine Zitterpartie.
Lange war unklar, ob das Fest
im grossen Rahmen stattfinden kann.
Wir wollten unbedingt in unserer
Heimatstadt Luzern etwas machen.
Wir dachten,
dass es für alle schön sei,
wieder ein wenig
in die Normalität zurückzukommen.
Jetzt haben wir mit einer Day Party
ein gutes Konzept erstellt.
Und wir können so
um 24 Uhr aufhören.
* Dynamische Musik *
Trotz aller Vorfreude spürt Manuel
auch eine leise Unsicherheit.
Neben all dem Schönen
ist auch immer etwas Angst dabei.
Ansteckungen
wären für uns natürlich nicht gut,
weil es lokal
Quarantäne-Verordnungen gibt.
D.h., es werden einzelne Hotels
oder einzelne Quartiere
unter Quarantäne gestellt.
Und das ...
Daran will ich gar nicht denken,
was dann wäre.
Man fragt sich auch:
Ist das gefährlich,
wenn 80 Leute kommen? Oder nicht?
Man weiss es nicht so genau.
Die Sorge ist nicht unbegründet.
Erst kürzlich wurde der erste Fall
eines Superspreaders bekannt.
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Am Seetalplatz in Emmenbrücke
machen sich Musikerin Claudia
Kienzler und Christoph Spielmann
an die Renovationsarbeiten
am Varieté Caleidoskop.
Claudia hat es im Januar übernommen,
dann kam der Shutdown.
Die Tourneepläne sind gefährdet.
Die beiden
sind seit gut einem Jahr ein Paar.
Erst seit einem Jahr arbeiten wir
gemeinsam auf der Bühne.
Auf eine gewisse Art
war das ein schnelles Kennenlernen.
Zu sehen, wie jemand arbeitet, sich
über Sachen aufregt, frustriert ist
oder Dinge können will,
die vielleicht nicht klappen.
Es ist ein Entdecken.
Nicht?
War es schlimm?
Nein, ich habe es sehr genossen.
Es ist super.
Ich finde, es funktioniert gut.
Ich glaube, wir sind Menschen,
die einander Raum geben.
Ja, auch bei der Fantasie.
Wir blocken keine Ideen ab,
sondern nehmen sie ernst,
wir arbeiten künstlerisch,
um sie auszuprobieren.
Wir geben ihnen eine Chance.
Diese Balance stimmt.
Es ist niemand direktiver
als der andere.
Und trotzdem sind wir
zwei sture Menschen.
Nicht nur die Varieté-Tournee
von 2021 ist infrage gestellt,
wegen Corona wurde alle Konzerte
der Profigeigerin abgesagt.
Das Los vieler Kulturschaffenden.
Auch in der Musik-Bar Meyers
mussten Konzerte abgesagt
oder verschoben werden.
Salut.
- Hallo.
Oh, hast du im Lockdown gemalt?
- Das hast du noch nicht gesehen.
Krass, super, schön.
Wer hat das gemacht?
Beni Müller, Beni Big Ben Müller.
Was möchtest du gerne?
Einen Espresso.
Betreiber Dominic Meyer
steht hinter der Bar.
Sieht man hier,
wer ein- und ausgegangen ist?
Das ist ja voll die Kontrolle.
- Das verschwindet wieder.
Dominic führt die Bar zusammen
mit seiner Frau Fiona.
Während des Shutdowns war ihr Betrieb
wochenlang geschlossen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Und dir?
Ja, also ja.
Gut.
Gut und nicht gut.
In der ganzen Kultur
läuft immer noch gar nichts.
Langfristig gesehen gibt es einen
Teil in mir, der sich Sorgen macht.
Bis im September ist alles abgesagt.
- Bis im September?- Ja.
Auch das KKL.
- Das sind über 1'000 Leute.
Und ich ... äh ...
- Ab September sind sie gebucht?
Ja, aber ob sie durchgeführt werden,
ist ungewiss.
Und mit einem solchen Lokal
arbeitet man nicht auf Gewinn.
Nein, gar nicht.
Im ersten Moment
fiel alles über mir zusammen.
Ich bekam extreme Existenzängste.
Domi und ich haben uns irgendwann
angeschaut und gesagt:
"Wir können
nichts an dieser Situation ändern."
"Entweder wir machen das Beste
daraus oder ..."
Jammern nützt nichts.
Es ändert nichts.
Genau, du musst unbedingt ans
Mothers Pride Konzert kommen.
26. September ist mal geplant.
Ist mal geplant?
- Ja.
Damit würden wir
eine kleine Konzertsaison ...
Die Hausband.
Wir hoffen sehr, dass bis dann
alles wieder normal ist.
Dominic ist Drummer
der Luzerner Kultband Mothers Pride.
Nach zehn Jahren planten sie
auf den Frühling ein Comeback.
Jetzt hoffen sie auf den Herbst.
* "The Storm At Sea"
gesungen von Mothers Pride *
* Jazzige Klänge *
Mittlerweile geht es im
Hotel Beau Séjour hoch zu und her.
Die Geburtstagsparty
macht Manuel Berger und seinem Team
Hoffnung auf bessere Zeiten.
In den letzten zwei Tagen
hatten wir kleinere Apéros.
Es war sehr schön, wenn wir am Abend
20 Leute im Saal hatten.
So war der Saal
nicht so gähnend leer.
Das war schon sehr gut,
ein Warm-up für heute.
Jetzt merkt man,
dass alle eintrudeln.
Am Schluss sind 85 Leute hier.
Wir sind megahappy,
dass schönes Wetter herrscht.
So können sie auch draussen sein.
Wir sind gut vorbereitet.
Es sollte eigentlich
alles schiefgehen.
Gäste bewirten und beherbergen
ist Manuels Leidenschaft.
Die Apérohäppchen
hat der gelernte Koch selbst gemacht.
Das Abendessen wird von
einem befreundeten Koch zubereitet.
Man sagt in der Küche: "Das
Mise en Place ist das halbe Leben."
Also die Vorbereitungsarbeiten.
Die Leute
scheinen sich wohlzufühlen.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall
alles sehr gechillt aus.
Diese Fotos werden Manuel
an einen Sommer erinnern,
der besser war, als erwartet.
* Klicken des Fotoapparates *
Full House
und die Terrasse voller Gäste.
Claudia Kienzler
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Weil ihr alle Konzerte weggebrochen
sind, ist jetzt Flexibilität gefragt,
genau wie bei ihrem Kollegen Sandro.
Er hat einen Take-Away eröffnet.
Sandro!
- Geht's gut?- Ja. Und dir?
Ja, bene, bene.
Hatte eben einen Ansturm.
Einen Ansturm?- Ja.
- Eine Ziegenkäse-Focaccia.
Hast du die Öffnungszeiten
verlängert?
Das gilt jetzt für immer.
Corona-Überbrückung, nicht wahr?
Nein, ich bin jetzt der Hauptmieter.
Jetzt kann ich mich hier einrichten.
Das Ziel ist, dass man mittags
hier gut essen kann.
Sandro wandelte sich
vom arbeitslosen Barbetreiber
zum vielbeschäftigten
Take-Away-Anbieter.
Essen zum Mitnehmen
passt in die Corona-Welt.
Wir haben noch eine Bar.
Dort wurden wir
wirklich lieb unterstützt.
Natürlich
hatten wir auch Kurzarbeit.
So war es quasie
ein gutes, künstliches Koma.
Hier konnte ich im Mai eröffnen.
Natürlich hatten wir hier
weniger Leute als sonst.
Aber wir konnten arbeiten.
Daher war es kein Problem.
Die Leute konnten etwas holen
und zack waren sie wieder weg.
Aber Neuerfindungen sind immer
vonnöten - auch ohne Virus.
Man kann nicht das Leben lang
das Gleiche machen.
Von daher ... Ja.
Danke für den Besuch.
- Hoffentlich bis bald.
Tschüss.
- Tschau.
Auch
die 39-jährige Violinistin Claudia
muss in diesen Zeiten
beweglich bleiben.
Ein Engagement
für eine Theaterproduktion
gibt ihr
eine Perspektive für den Herbst.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Roland Küng hatte einen harten Tag.
Seine beiden Kinder
bringen ihn auf andere Gedanken.
Wir war es heute, Janik?
Heute war's gut.
Es hat mir sehr gefallen,
v.a. am Morgen.
Was musstest du machen?
- Es gab ein Firmenführung.
Das ist doch egal.
Sohn Janik will Mediamatiker werden.
Heute war er schnuppern.
Was hast du heute?
Am Morgen
hatten wir eine Firmenführung.
Es ist keine grosse Firma.
Wie viele Leute hat sie?
- Sie nannten keine genaue Zahl.
Ich denke,
es sind ungefähr 20 Leute.
Moment.
Aber wie ist dein Gefühl?
Man hat doch ein Gefühl,
wenn man rausgeht.
Es war mega cool.
- Hast du dich auch gut verkauft?
Ja, sehr.
Bist du sicher?
- Ja.
Du hattest also ein gutes Gefühl,
Fragen gestellt
und Interesse gezeigt?
Es war gut.
Was machst du jetzt?
Jetzt?- Ja, mit den Firmen,
bei denen du dich beworben hast.
Ich warte jetzt sicher, bis sie
zurückgeschrieben haben und dann ...
Papa sagt etwas anderes.
Nein, es geht um eine Lehrstelle.
Ich würde ihnen am Freitag
eine E-Mail schreiben.
Welchen?
- Der GLS und der Messe.
Du bedankst dich höflich für das
angenehme, gut Bewerbungsgespräch.
Dein Interesse
sei nach wie vor ungebrochen gross.
Und du würdest dich sehr freuen,
wenn du die Lehre
bei ihnen machen dürftest.
Du lachst jetzt, aber so läuft das.
Dein Interesse anmelden.
Dann wissen sie: Der macht
etwas dafür, der will kommen.
Gut, das mache ich.
- Hat es dir gefallen?- Mega.
Er hat sich gut vorbereitet.
Er musste sich selber vorbereiten.
Danach kam er zu mir
und stellte mir seine Fragen.
Ich habe den
potenziellen Lehrmeister gespielt
und habe ihm Fragen gestellt.
Er hat das sehr, sehr gut gemacht -
nur schon in der Übungsrunde.
Er hat mir schon sehr viel geholfen.
Er sagte mir auch,
was ich bei Bewerbungsgesprächen
nicht sagen
und was ich sagen sollte.
Ich glaube, es kam gut, hoffe ich.
Seit der Scheidung der Eltern
leben Linda und Janik
bei der Mutter gleich um die Ecke.
So sind sie auch oft bei ihrem Vater.
Familie ist immer wichtig.
Ich liebe meine beiden Kinder
über alles.
Es ist natürlich jetzt noch mehr ...
Gerade nach einem Tag wie heute
kann ich viel besser abschalten.
Wir sprechen über andere Themen,
es umgibt mich eine Unbeschwertheit.
Wenn sie nicht da sind
und ich alleine bin,
denke ich länger über den Tag nach
und überlege mir dies und das.
Von daher ist es positiv, dass ich
sehr schnell abschalten kann,
und irgendwann sind sie im Bett.
Dann dreht sich evtl. das Karussell
in meinem Kopf wieder weiter.
En Guete.
Am Sonntag
feiert Linda Erstkommunion.
In der Kirche wird sie
auf der Blockflöte vorspielen.
Ist für nächsten Sonntag
alles klar, Spatz?
Ja.- Musstest du
auch in der Kirche üben?
Morgen.
Dann ist es aber vorbei?
Oder musst du noch mehr üben?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich am Freitag noch üben muss.
Noch einmal, aber ...
Aber nicht mehr Flöte üben?
Morgen muss ich die Flöte mitnehmen.
In die Kirche?
- Ja.
Weil ich am Sonntag vorspiele.
Ist es gut?
- Ja, sehr.- Es ist gut.
Eine volle Kirche
und ein Familienfest:
Im Sommer 2020 ist das noch möglich.
Im Kleintheater Luzern soll in vier
Monaten Premiere gefeiert werden -
vor richtigem Publikum.
Claudia Kienzler
ist froh um dieses Engagement.
Die Musikerin
hat auch als Darstellerin Erfahrung.
So hat sie auch schon mit Regisseur
Christoph Marthaler gearbeitet.
Die Schauspieler proben für
eine musikalische Kindergeschichte
über das Leben,
die Freundschaft und den Tod.
Das ist
ein weiterer Kostümvorschlag.
Wir suchen immer Kostüme
und probieren sie aus.
Jetzt geht es darum,
ob ich mich darin wohlfühle.
Die Handlung: Eine Ente muss sterben.
Doch als sie den Tod trifft,
werden die beiden unerwartet Freunde.
In Corona-Zeiten, wo das Sterben
unverhoffte Präsenz erhält,
gewinnt auch das Stück an Aktualität.
Das sind schon zehn Schichten.
Da kann man 20 Schichten machen.
Die Proben haben eben erst begonnen.
Ich hätte gerne: Die Ente schläft.
Den Nachtgesang
als Übergang,
um in die neue Szene zu kommen,
in der die Ente erwacht.
* Krächzen der Geige *
Oh!
* Aufgeregtes Schnattern *
* Schnelle Geigentöne *
* Zischen *
Wenn ich sterbe,
dann hat es dort einen See.
* Einsetzen der Geige *
Einen richtigen See.
Einen solchen See, dass ich nicht
nicht einmal das Ende des Sees sehe.
Und überall wachsen Seerosen.
Ich fand megaschön,
dass die Universumsdinger,
die wir beim Anfang haben,
jetzt wiederkamen.
Das ist alles improvisiert, nichts
ist abgemacht, nichts einstudiert.
Im Moment sammeln wir
noch Material und Möglichkeiten.
Wir schauen,
wie weit man gehen kann.
Wo die Grenzen sind.
Einmal über die Grenzen gehen, dann
hat man wieder neue Erkenntnisse.
Du hast mich geweckt. Du hast
irgendwie etwas anderes eingebracht.
Um den Morgen anzustossen.
Das ist cool.
Der ganze letzte Teil
war ein Wecken.
Es hatte mehr Bewegung drin.
Und dann dieses Wecken.
Und, ich habe dir
noch eine Fliege geschenkt.
Die Premiere
ist auf den 1. November geplant.
Aber ob sie stattfinden kann,
ist noch völlig offen.
Einen solchen Sommer
hat Luzern noch nie erlebt.
Die fehlenden Touristen
hinterlassen tiefe Spuren.
Die Souvenirgeschäfte bleiben leer.
Für Bojan,
den Hauswart bei Casagrande,
gibt es dennoch
Unterhaltsarbeiten zu erledigen.
Der Chef sehnt sich
nach dem Trubel der Vergangenheit.
* Kuckucksrufe *
Die Krise trifft viele Unternehmen.
Auch der traditionsreiche
Schifffahrtsbetrieb Bucher
sitzt auf dem Trockenen.
Ich denke, wir müssen lernen ...
Konntest du im Juli und August
ein wenig aufholen?
Das ist schwierig.
Aufholen konnten wir nicht.
Wir haben
keine internationale Touristen.
Das ist natürlich das Hauptgeschäft,
wie bei dir auch.
Wir haben auch
109 Leute in der Kurzarbeit.
Das ist wahnsinnig für die.
Bei uns haben sieben Kurzarbeit.
Bald ist der Sommer vorbei.
Dann werden auch
die Schweizer Touristen wegbleiben.
Darum hat Robert Casagrande
keine guten Nachrichten
für die Angestellten
der Filiale beim Löwendenkmal.
Wie geht's?
- Ja, eigentlich gut.
Es könnte besser sein.
Ja, es war
die letzten paar Wochen ernüchternd.
Heute, bei diesem schönen Wetter,
sind natürlich
auch die Einheimischen nicht da.
Und die Touristen
gehen auch in die Stadt,
vielleicht zum Löwendenkmal,
aber nicht shoppen.
Wie haben uns entschlossen, dass wir
am 5. August wieder schliessen,
sicher bis Mitte September.
Dann müsst ihr wieder
in die Kurzarbeit gehen.
Das ist sehr schade, auch für uns.
Ja, aber leider sind
die Zahlen nicht so gut,
wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben.
Das sieht man
und kann man gut nachfühlen.
Dieses Jahr
wird es schwierig werden.
Hoffnung besteht für nächstes Jahr.
- Ja.
Tschüss, bis bald.
Ich bin nächste Woche nicht hier.
Am Mittwochmorgen bin ich da.
- Okay, super.
Bis später.
- Bye, bye.
Bye, bye.
Ich bin alleinerziehend.
Ich habe
einen Sohn und eine Katze.
Wir geben uns Mühe,
irgendwie da durchzukommen.
Wir haben immer wieder Feedbacks
von den Oberen,
der Geschäftsleitung.
Die gibt etwas Halt
und ein sicheres Gefühl.
Darum geht es noch.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt Leute,
die hat es schlimmer getroffen.
In der nächsten Folge:
Die Krise hat für Souvenirhändler
Casagrande grosse Auswirkungen.
Wir verloren immense Summen.
Wir mussten leider
zehn Leute entlassen.
Für ihr Varieté muss Claudia Kienzler
dringend Geld auftreiben.
Es sind
riesige Investitionsleistungen,
die jetzt getätigt werden müssen.
Und Roland Küng bricht
sein Versprechen an die Belegschaft.
Noch vor einem Monat
war mein absolutes Ziel:
An Weihnachten
haben alle Mitarbeiter
eine sichere Stelle bei uns.
Aber ja ... Es geht nicht.
Es geht schlicht und einfach
nicht mehr.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2021